a picture one meter tall is up here here
it is in fact I'll put some color on it
so you okay pictures up the ads on the
wall and you've got the eye of someone
looking at it down here at a FIFA I
that's confusing anyway and you have
this sub angle subtended at the eye by
the pic shot okay so that's angle B II T
they're calling a theta okay so you can
see if I moved the observer if I move
them closer to the wall or further away
from the wall that angle theta is gonna
change it's gonna get bigger smaller
although really sure which way it's good
to go but it's gonna change is the
important thing
and then you've got a few other things
that are peace information on there show
that theta equals and then they give you
a function okay so what kind of result
we got here um I've got theta in terms
of two right angle triangles a city on
top of one another okay so let's have a
look at what this angle here in the
corner be EP is first okay now the
formula sorry that the the equation
they've given us is all the terms of ten
inverses okay so we're gonna start off
with tans and Bridget images later which
makes sense because you've got an
opposite and adjacent side in these
right angle triangles okay so here's the
first thing that I write I suppose if
you want to be really Danny you could
say even triangle because we're just
learning the right angle angle three
years right okay there's one so if I say
well what's PE be equal to not the tan
of PEP then that's where my antenna bus
comes
yes okay now what about this other angle
in here this whole angle in the biggest
right angle triangle okay if that's PE T
I can use exactly the same tree and
because it's three plus one
that's why do we fall that's the
opposite side so in triangle T the same
angle in the corner is equal to
Florida's yeah so now if I just want the
able ones I take okay so you see I'm
always there right the angle I want is
the difference between the two angles
that I just found okay so I can say
theta is equal to the big angle minus
okay so this part yeah any questions so
far that part okay that part's just set
up yet now by the way it's worth
learning you know this kind of part of
the question they're they're sort of
guiding you through the process but
sometimes they'll just give you the
situation and they'll their interest
rate on Part B which says show that
theater is maximized for a certain value
of x okay so we have to sometimes work
all of this out on our own for that own
comic crackers so if I'm looking for a
maximum I'm looking for the biggest
angle theta that I can get right so it's
kind of like we usually used to have Y
over here y equals something with
respect to X but it's theta that's fine
we can still differentiate with respect
to X it's just that we've got at least
10 MS ones right okay so chain rule
right which is what we practiced last
lesson let's do the inside first what's
the derivative of 4 of X it's 4 X to the
minus 1 what's the derivative yeah good
minus 4 x squared that's X to the minus
2 down the bottom okay there's the
inside what's the outside what is what
is tenuous it's 1 over yes so usually we
would have x squared here but X is not
the inside functions it's 4 over X isn't
it
so it should be 16x squared there good
and we'll just rehearse that form of
this function over here - this is going
to do the same thing but I've got 3
squared on x squared instead of okay
it's always there let's tidy up just a
little bit this is positive here because
of the double negative that's negative
so I'm gonna switch them around so it's
not minus in front which is weird so I'm
gonna get 3 over now what happens to
this denominator those factions are
getting canceled I'm gonna get x squared
plus 9 so okay that's that's from just
over here and here that minus sign over
there
four on the top and in much the same way
the denominator gets a little bit simple
so there's my derivative okay now what
why dad differentiate him what was the
point where am I going to take that
result good yeah so I'm looking for
maximum right so I'm gonna say four
potential turning points this derivative
ought to be zero okay so in other words
this is equal zero which a first looks
terrible but actually when you get this
on the other side and as I will in a
second
cross multiply actually works out really
really support right what are we going
to get over here 3x
excuse me squared plus 48 for x squared
plus 36 so if I bring everything around
x squared is equal to 12
yes okay now what
that's right so out of this line I'm
going to get two solutions
so I'll write those two and then I'll
disregard the negative one okay so I'm
gonna get fossil - there's a four in
there right so that'll become two root
three okay but because of what XE is
nearly a distance right that's why I can
say X is gonna be greater than zero okay
therefore it's a positive one only okay
so now that was actually where we were
that's the number we expected to arrive
at am I finished
yeah I don't know because I said this is
potential twenty points right so I found
a stationary point but I don't know if
it is actually a turning point and I
don't know what climb template is it is
so how should we go about it what do you
think is the best approach remembering
that this is a derivative I'm gonna draw
a table what is two root three by the
way root threes like what point seven
we'll put seven something this is kind
of like three point four ish right so
you can pick three on one side and four
on the other okay and you can join
yourself up a table
okay so I'll wait for you guys to get
some values I think if it turns out to
be a bit of a and so the first thing is
be suspicious or you're a dancer I would
probably expect especially when they say
to show that right
I would I would expect that maybe I've
done something wrong with my derivative
okay
because usually having got it right you
know it's not that hard to put the
values in we're more likely to have gone
wrong rather than evaluating it is that
I've got this through b-roll okay it's
suspicious that I would have gotten it
wrong because I've got the right station
right so so it had to be valid to some
extent but maybe check your calculator
even that you're inputting it correctly
okay so you should get oh we're looking
for a max right so we should get
positive zero negative okay has anyone
been value for any of these oh this one
okay so that is increasing just like we
wanted okay there's some other value for
for
good okay so this is what we're
expecting up flat across so therefore
it's a matter which is what we need
okay excellent now let's read the last
part the question because some of the
hard parts of this is just interpreting
the way it's worded okay sure that the
maximum angle subtended by the pink shot
at E is and then they give you a value
okay now what actually took you about it
would have been I saw if it just said
use the language they've already
introduced right what is that angle the
speed subtended at the observer by the
picture and the angle is Theta right
there's the picture and there's the
angle it's attending okay
so really what they want us to work out
is just theta at that point okay so
these are the Sun so hot let's take our
x value which is the maximum and let's
plug it into our expression for theta
which we worked out in part
okay now I think it was 10 of us 4 and X
and then 3 on X right so I'll go full on
3 - okay now what do I do
okay I will I will take the 10 to both
sides now you know that you're going to
have a ticket and both sides eventually
he's why these two numbers whatever they
are they are different to each other
right so they're not going to talk
nicely while they're still nestled
inside their 10 inverse functions okay
so you can't read of them I'm gonna have
to take 10 use my expansion formula for
tan and then they can you track Nutella
and I'll take tan to visit you before I
do that though there's something I can
promise you to make it a little easier
for myself right yeah these these were
terrible right let's let's make them a
little bit on what are we going here
that's going to be canceled that's just
2 or 3 and what's this going to be rude
thread - thanks they're super cool yeah
ok so now I'm in a position where it's
nice and simple I can take care of both
sides okay so 10 Theodore in the heel
now I could write it out but I think
you've got it in your head well enough
but if you're taking 10 on there this is
a difference like a minus B what's equal
to what's the expansion it's the
fraction right what's on the top 10 a
- can't be right it's the difference
yeah the plus is on the bottom okay so
I'm gonna have tan of tannish okay which
is just equal to whatever that is right
so let's have a look at the top that's
tan of tan inverse of 2 or 3 which is
just 2 it
to honor three sorry um this is the
second one and then what do we have a
model one plus the product now because
it was chosen very conveniently right
the part of these two will be just one
right because they're reciprocals so I'm
gonna get one plus one so that's 2 times
root 3 minus root 3 on 2 all divided by
2 so far so good
let's do the division so I'm going to
100 3 3 3 4 4 so now I've got the lid of
my fraction put it together what's a
good comment denominator to use you can
use for a 3 right that'll work that'll
put into two fractions i but but you've
been given a you've been given a
destination right you don't want to get
it to anything they've told you if we
should get 2 root 3 112 right that's
what kind of makes sense because that's
gonna let us it's gonna let the
numerator kind of super fly together ok
ok so if I make it 12 let's see I'll do
it on to a couple of extras never seen
mr. three on three
so this is gonna be 4 root 3 minus 3
root 3
on 12 berries you see okay yeah so let's
make a new column I've got 10 feet up on
the left hand side root 3 on 12 on the
right hand side and I'm there
finished okay just a curiosity what is
that like can someone get a calculator
out and retainer versa what is the angle
I'm just kind of curious put what four
radians in this degrees as well I'm
still does that sound about right
it looks like it's in the ballpark now
whatever you do max many questions I
hope you get into the habit all boys
checking your results again particular
in there we don't ones like that and
it's not intuitive what that's equal to
just to make sure you've got a reason to
resolve
I know key they expect it you know find
this value and they told you but you
don't always get that not true
any questions on any part of that